This episode of D News is
brought to you by Toyota.
Guys, this was 3D printed
and I'm going to eat it.
Hey, guys, it's Trace
here for D News.
I'm at CES 2014 and we're
in the 3d printing area.
It's still the hot
technology this year.
They have a whole
section devoted just
to all the 3D printers at CES.
3D printers can use metal,
they can use ceramics,
they can use plastics.
They can print bio cells.
They can even print food.
And that's what this
little guy is right here.
Even though 3D printing
is super big right now,
it's still kind of a super
nerdy, nerdy nerd nerd level
of technology.
They've sold 68,000 3D
printers, according to one poll.
And the industry is
about $2.2 billion.
But most of them are
way too complicated
for the average consumer.
And this year at
CES, they're trying
to change that and bring them
more into a lower price range
and easier to use.
So this is by 3-D Systems.
It's printed food, you guys.
And we're going to try it.
OK, guys, here we go.
It's good.
It kind of tastes like the
marshmallow in Lucky Charms.
The MakerBot Replicator Z18 is
the largest model available.
And it was announced
here at CES.
It's 12 by 12 by 18 inches.
That is huge.
And you can do all sorts
of cool stuff with it.
And we talked to Bre
Pettis, CEO of MakerBot,
a little bit about it.
What's the best part about it,
other than it's giant, right?
Is that it?
So the MakerBot Replicator
Z18 is our biggest 3D printer.
We launched a small,
medium and large one.
And this is the big one.
And there's a couple things
that are special about this.
It's got the MakerBot
Replicator Smart Extruder.
This sends you a message when
you need to add more filament.
And it'll send it to your phone.
It'll say, hey
your model's done.
Come pick it up and get
the next one started.
It's got a camera in it, so
you can take pictures of things
that you make.
You can monitor your
progress and broadcast out
your latest creation
on social networks.
The MakerBot Replicator
Z18 has a heated
build chamber, which actually
keeps the models dimensionally
stable, as it's being made.
Inside the 3D printer is the
MakerBot Replicator 3D printing
platform, the
electronics and software.
All three 3D printers have
very, very powerful electronics
and software behind them.
And this one's no different.
The MakerBot Replicator
Z18 is for the person
who doesn't want any limits.
They want to think big.
They want to go-- they
don't want any limitations.
And the third in our lineup
of 3D printers at CES
is the DaVinci 1.0.
It's made by XYZ Printing,
whose parent company was a 2D
printer.
So they're able to
make this guy for $499.
Yeah, $499.
It's super cheap.
But it's made by a 2D printer
that now makes 3D printers.
They just added
that extra D. And it
has proprietary
print cartridges.
So that's pretty much it for
3D printing here at CES 2014.
We've got a big guy.
We've got a cheap guy.
And we've got a tasty guy.
Which one of those would you
pick, if you could have one?
Let us know down
below in the comments.
And thanks a lot for
watching D News, everybody.
Make sure you
subscribe for more.
We'll see you next time.
Thanks again to Toyota for
sponsoring our CES coverage.